the world's best players are coming to
Qatar this year inspiring boys and girls
alike
eight-year-old Reem al-sani is just one
of the young players defying stereotypes
about the region I started playing
football from watching matches and I
started to be better and better so I
continued to play when you told your
parents you wanted to play football what
did they say to you they were
encouraging me to play more and more and
get better
the coaches here say women's football in
Qatar is still at work in progress but
believe the country is heading in the
right direction
yeah I didn't really know what to expect
um because I've never really been out
here before
um but when I arrived and I saw the
girls playing there was already a lot
but since me coming in and and the
programs that we've been running we've
like tripled the amount of numbers uh
since the start so that can only keep
growing and growing and it's a positive
impact that we can make on on the future
of girls football football's governing
body FIFA says it won 60 million women
across the globe playing the game by
2026. now that's double the number that
we're involved in football less than a
decade ago
Danish international Nadia Nadeem is an
ambassador for the Qatar 2022 World Cup
born in Afghanistan her family fled to
Denmark after her father was executed by
the Taliban two decades ago football was
almost My Savior I would say I think it
has told me everything that I know
it kind of integrated me in a society
very very quick it helped me to learn
the language got Danish friends
understand you know the differences
similarities of these two cultures
because they are very different why if
you could go all the way there at this
training session in Doha football has
brought together girls from at least 30
different countries
I was born in Manchester and football's
a big part of the local culture whilst
it allowed me to be like sort of free on
the pitch it also discipline teaches me
discipline to keep going and get back up
again
generation of footballers out to prove
that inclusivity is a reality not a
distant Target pharah Ismail Al Jazeera
Doha